.
* Melancholische Klavierklänge *
Wir sind am Times Square und es
ist unglaublich leer und ruhig hier.
Für Broadway ist das
ein ganz tiefer Einschnitt.
Wir sind hier im Café Select.
Es ist schon
seit etwa drei Wochen geschlossen.
Natürlich ist der ganze Glanz
und Allure nicht da,
wenn keine Leute hier sind.
(Französisch) Wegen des Coronavirus
ist alles tot, alles zu.
Im Moment ist das New York, das ich
sehe, ein New York, das Angst hat.
(Französisch) Ich nähe diese Maske,
weil mein Vater
draussen filmen gehen
und wegen des Coronavirus
eine Maske tragen muss.
Wir wohnen in New York
und New York ist einer von den meist
kontaminierten Staaten in Amerika.
Und die Regierung von New York will,
dass wir Masken tragen.
Zurzeit tragen alle Leute
eine Maske.
Wir müssen uns gut schützen,
damit wir nicht krank werden.
Die Corona-Krise ist Anfang März
in New York angekommen.
Seither müssen
die New Yorker zu Hause bleiben.
Die Metropole
wurde sozusagen geschlossen.
Die Schulen werden frühestens
im September wieder geöffnet.
1,1 Mio. Kinder müssen sich
an Fernunterricht gewöhnen.
Die Stadt, die immer wach war,
ist im Tiefschlaf.
Im Moment ist es manchmal
fast etwas spooky.
Das ist schon etwas, das ich mir
nie erträumt, nie erwartet hätte.
Dass man in einer Riesenstadt
wie New York
in der Metro den Blick
umherschweifen lassen kann
und weit und breit
keinen Menschen sieht
Die Bernerin Eliane Brechbühl
ist Anfang Februar
in New York angekommen,
um im Mount-Sinai-Spital für ihren
Master in Nanomedizin zu forschen.
Dann kam das Coronavirus,
traf die Metropole mit voller Wucht
und änderte alles.
Ich habe mein Projekt
komplett umorientiert.
Seit der Corona-Krise,
also seit dem 20. März,
dürfen wir im Labor
quasi nicht mehr arbeiten.
In unserem Labor haben wir aber
ein neues Projekt gestartet,
das mit COVID-19 zu tun hat.
So erhielten wir eine Bewilligung,
daran weiterzuarbeiten.
So habe ich nun die Chance,
da mitzuarbeiten.
Während Eliane gegen COVID-19 kämpft,
müssen die New Yorker
zu Hause bleiben
und sich auf Leute
wie David Nkusi verlassen,
die ihnen nun das Essen bringen.
Der 36-jährige Fahrradkurier
ist in Vevey aufgewachsen.
Heute lebt er in Queens.
Vor dem Coronavirus
habe ich eine Ausbildung an
der New Yorker Universität gemacht
und danach angefangen, mit Produ-
zenten und Regisseuren zu arbeiten.
Das war mein Beruf,
seit ich 2013 hier angekommen bin.
Dann hat die Corona-Krise begonnen
und ich habe alles verloren.
Ich konnte plötzlich
nicht mehr arbeiten
und meine Zukunft war ungewiss,
weil man nicht wusste, wann das
endet. Also habe ich mir gesagt:
"Ich muss einen Job finden,
um weiter genug zu verdienen."
Ein Freund
hat mir von Postmates erzählt.
Das ist eine Firma,
die Lebensmittel nach Hause liefert.
Als Kuriere dürfen wir
im Moment arbeiten,
genau wie die Krankenschwestern,
wie die Polizei oder die Feuerwehr.
Wir sind vermutlich die Einzigen,
die im Moment noch raus dürfen.
Ich sagte mir: "Okay, warum nicht?"
Jeden zweiten Tag
fährt David Nkusi mit der U-Bahn
von seinem Haus in Queens
nach Manhattan.
Er liefert Lebensmittel
und andere Sachen,
die zu Hause blockierte New Yorker
online bestellen.
Am Anfang habe ich
nicht wirklich ans Risiko gedacht,
weil uns niemand gesagt hat,
wie tödlich das Virus ist.
Der Präsident meinte im Fernsehen,
es sei wie eine normale Grippe.
Deshalb dachte ich: "Okay, wenn ich
aufpasse, kann ich weiter arbeiten."
Ich habe erst allmählich
gemerkt, wie gefährlich es ist,
als ich die Reaktion der Leute
gesehen habe.
Seit dem Anfang der Krise
kannst du die Dankbarkeit
in den Augen der Leute sehen.
Es ist,
als würde man ihr Leben retten.
Hallo, schön, dich zu sehen.
Geht's dir gut?
Ja.
Hast du keine Angst
vor dem Coronavirus?
Doch.
Deshalb hast du eine Maske.
- Ich brauche das Geld.
Nach wochenlangen Ausgangssperren
fordert die Coronavirus-Krise
allmählich ihren Tribut ―
und trifft v.a. Arme.
Allein in den ersten Wochen der Krise
haben in New York 1,2 Mio. Menschen
ihre Arbeit verloren.
In New Jersey haben sich
im ersten Monat 718'000 Menschen
arbeitslos gemeldet.
Hunger ist zu einem echten Problem
geworden für viele Amerikaner,
die sich ihre Miete und Lebensmittel
nicht mehr leisten können.
Einige haben sich entschlossen,
zu helfen.
(Deutsch mit amerikanischem Akzent)
Mein Name ist Harley Breite.
Ich bin ein Anwalt in Paterson,
New Jersey.
Ich wurde in Basel geboren und
kam mit drei Jahren nach Amerika.
Mein Vater, ein polnischer Jude, hat
die Todeslager von Hitler überlebt.
Wir liefern Lebensmittel und Vorräte
an Menschen, die sie brauchen.
Ich habe vor vielen Jahren jemanden
gerettet und der kennt jemanden,
der angeblich so viel Hühnchen,
Rindfleisch und Steak besorgen kann,
wie er will.
Also werde ich heute
600 Pfund Lebensmittel
und Kisten mit Toilettenpapier
und Papiertüchern abholen.
Das alles werden wir Leuten geben,
die es brauchen.
Ich werde vorne parken.
Dieses Zeug ist viel zu viel wert.
Sein Cousin
stand damals vor Gericht.
Es ging um eine Schusswaffe.
Und ich habe ihn gerettet.
Menschen erinnern sich daran,
wer ihnen geholfen hat,
als sie am Ende waren.
Ich habe auch noch Papiertücher.
Nimm ein paar Steaks!
Hallo! Braucht ihr Klopapier?
Ja, das brauchen wir auch!
Die einzigen Menschen, die man
in den leeren Strassen noch sieht,
sind Fahrradkuriere wie David.
Für die 25'000 Restaurants und Bars,
die in New York City
geschlossen worden sind,
ist die Corona-Krise
eine Katastrophe.
So auch für das berühmte
Schweizer Café Select in Soho,
eines von drei Restaurants,
die dem Zürcher Musikproduzenten
Oliver Stumm gehören.
Den Schlüssel für diese Tür
haben wir leider
vor etwa acht Jahren verloren.
Somit gibt es nur noch zwei Wege,
um reinzukommen.
Man kann das Fenster aufmachen, denn
das kann man nicht abschliessen.
Einfach niemandem sagen!
Oder ich muss durch den Keller rein.
Es geschah nicht
von einem Tag auf den anderen,
aber doch innert ein paar Tagen.
Die Anweisungen
kamen fast stündlich:
Dies dürfe man nicht mehr,
jenes dürfe man nicht mehr.
Nach einer halben Woche hiess es,
wir müssten ganz schliessen.
Also schlossen wir halt ganz.
Wir mussten sofort reagieren, denn
es kam sofort kein Geld mehr rein,
aber sehr viel Geld ging immer noch
raus. Das geht wahnsinnig schnell.
Somit habe ich alle Angestellten
sofort entlassen und sagte ihnen,
dass sie sich sofort beim
Arbeitslosenamt anmelden sollen.
Jedes Restaurant hatte vermutlich
allein
wegen der frischen Lebensmittel,
die man nach fünf, sechs Tagen
einfach entsorgen musste,
einen Schaden von 10'000-15'000 $.
Das ist Boris von Yello.
Das ist Ursula Andress.
Klibi. Bernhard Russi.
Roger.
Ein Restaurant
in der Grösse des Café Select
braucht 100'000-150'000
auf dem Bankkonto,
um überhaupt
die Türen öffnen zu können.
Ich bin willens,
Schulden aufzunehmen,
um diese Restaurants
wieder eröffnen zu können.
Aber zuerst müsste ich mich
mit den Hausbesitzern hinsetzen
und neue Verträge aushandeln.
Denn die Miete,
die wir bezahlt haben,
werden wir nie mehr bezahlen können.
Es wird sich nicht wieder
so einpendeln wie zuvor.
Die Welt
ist zum Stillstand gekommen.
Ich glaube, die Menschheit
wird nicht mehr dieselbe sein
in den nächsten paar Jahren -
oder nie mehr.
Oh, boy. Let's see.
Heieiei.
There's even more lights.
It's all about the lights.
Da sind einfach so Dinge,
die ich gefunden habe,
in der Schweiz und so.
Kleine Dinge, die einen, äh ...
... an die Schweiz und so erinnern.
Falls die Situation eintritt,
dass wir nicht wiedereröffnen,
kann ich natürlich
nichts von hier verkaufen,
weil die Hälfte der Restaurants
nicht mehr öffnen werden,
also ist niemand an einem Kühl-
schrank, Herd oder so interessiert.
D.h., man kann einfach zur Tür
hinaus und ... das war's dann.
* Melancholische Musik *
My state of mind ist,
dass man alles infrage stellen muss,
mit allem neu anfangen muss.
Man soll nicht meinen, der Staat
rette einen als Einzelnen
oder als kleinen Betrieb.
Man muss versuchen,
sich wieder hochzuarbeiten
und eine neue Welt zu erarbeiten,
die für Normalsterbliche
funktioniert.
Nirgendwo in New York City
ist die Corona-Krise sichtbarer
als am Broadway
und auf dem Times Square.
Normalerweise besuchen
Hunderttausende den Times Square,
und Tausende weitere
bevölkern die legendären Theater
am benachbarten Broadway.
Aber an dem Tag, an dem wir
die Schauspielerin, Sängerin
und Immobilienmaklerin Sue Mathys
aus Küsnacht treffen,
ist der Times Square absolut leer.
* Schwungvoller Musical-Song:
"Rose's Turn" *
# Curtain up!
# Light the lights!
Das ist ein Stück
aus dem Musical "Gypsy".
Momma Rose singt es.
Sie ist eine unzerstörbare
sog. stage mother,
eine Mutter, die ihre Kinder
auf die Bühne schicken will.
Sie ist ein wunderbarer Charakter,
weil sie einfach eine ist,
die durch alles durchpflügt
und sagt: "Wir gehen nicht unter!"
Es passt in dem Sinn sehr gut
zu dieser, wie soll ich sagen ...
... zum Mindset, zur Einstellung
der New Yorker, die sagen:
"Wir überleben das!"
# Some people got it
and make it pay.
# Some people
can't even give it away.
# This people's got it and this
people's spreadin' it around!
Ich bin auch arbeitslos, ja.
Ich habe mich auch angemeldet.
Sie haben jetzt neu geregelt,
dass auch Selbstständigtätige
Arbeitslosengelder beziehen können.
Ich habe mich angemeldet, weiss aber
noch nicht, ob ich qualifiziert bin
und etwas bekomme,
aber ich hoffe es sehr.
Ich komme jetzt auch
in grosse Schwierigkeiten.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, das ist
in meinem Leben nichts Unbekanntes.
Ich habe es
in meinem früheren Beruf,
also auch in meinem jetzigen,
den ich nicht mehr so häufig ausübe,
im Theater, sehr oft erlebt,
dass man an einen Punkt kommt,
an dem man nicht weiss,
wie es weitergeht.
Wir wissen es jetzt alle nicht.
Ich habe da eine Art déformation
professionelle vom Theater,
indem ich finde:
The show must go on!
Man muss jetzt flexibel sein,
wir müssen alle schauen,
wie sich unser Leben verändert
aufgrund dessen, was passiert.
Niemand weiss, wie man damit umgehen
soll, denn so etwas gab es noch nie.
Wir müssen flexibel bleiben
und uns anpassen.
Das ist das Richard Rodgers Theater,
wo normalerweise "Hamilton" läuft.
Das ist einer der neuen,
grossen Broadway-Hits.
Sogar hier läuft gar nichts mehr.
Hier läuft das Musical "Tina".
Tina Turner lebt ja heute
in Küsnacht am Zürichsee,
wo ich aufgewachsen bin.
# Some people got it
and make it pay.
# Some people
can't even give it away.
# This people's got it and this
people's spreadin' it around!
Es ist natürlich heartbreaking.
Man weiss auch nicht, welche Shows
nach dieser Pause wieder spielen.
Für mich ist das Theater
immer ein Ort,
wo man Menschen bewegen,
inspirieren kann.
Ich denke, die Leute brauchen das.
Die Menschen
brauchen Ermutigung im Leben.
Gerade in Zeiten, wo es
schwierig ist, wo man mutlos ist,
wo man ... Ängste hat.
In der Nähe des Times Square
befindet sich das UN-Hauptquartier.
Es ist seit Wochen geschlossen.
Hier arbeitet die Baslerin
Mirjana Spoljaric-Egger,
wenn sie nicht UNO-Entwicklungs-
programme vor Ort leitet.
Das UNDP
hat in den letzten zwei Jahren
massiv in die Digitalisierung
investiert.
D.h., wir sind vollständig operativ
in allen Ländern,
wo das UNDP tätig ist,
inklusive in Jemen und Somalia,
also in Ländern wo es schon ohne
die COVID-Krise sehr schwierig war.
Ich finde es bewundernswert,
wie stark, pragmatisch und geduldig
die New Yorker sind.
Es ist eine Stadt,
die unglaublich viel aushalten kann.
Wenn man sieht, wie stark -
am stärksten von allen eigentlich -
sie betroffen war,
wie viele Leute gestorben sind
und wie schnell sich die Leute
aufrafften, Lösungen zu finden ...
Und v.a., wie innovativ
und solidarisch die Menschen sind.
Wir sammeln Geld, die Restaurants
kochen fürs Spitalpersonal,
jeden Abend wird geklatscht.
Es ist eine starke Stadt.
Eine von Harleys Lebensmittel-
lieferungen ist für Fortina Reyes.
Die mexikanische Einwanderin wohnt
gegenüber eines der Krankenhäuser,
die am stärksten betroffen sind.
(Spanisch) Steaks! Und Bagels.
Kennen Sie Bagels?
Für jüdische Menschen.
Danke.
- Gott sei mit dir.
Ich kann nicht raus,
weil ich zwei Töchter habe.
Und ich liebe meine Töchter.
Also sage ich mir: "Wenn ich mich
mit der Krankheit anstecke,
wo bleiben dann meine Töchter?"
Ich habe nichts mehr. Alles, was ich
habe, brauche ich für die Miete.
Für alles andere
habe ich gar nichts mehr.
So viele Patienten
werden hierher gebracht,
Tag und Nacht.
Ich gehe ins Badezimmer und sehe
die Krankenwagen, die ankommen.
Manchmal zwei, drei Wagen
auf einmal.
Ich habe Panik.
Die Lage ist weiterhin schlimm.
Heute war einer der schwierigsten
Tage meines Lebens.
Wir haben heute viel Tod gesehen.
Vor der Corona-Krise
arbeitete Jason Shatkin
als Spezialist für Lungenerkrankungen
in einer Privatpraxis.
Jetzt leitet er die
Intensivstation eines Krankenhauses
in der Umgebung von New York.
(Mann) Sie machen
eine wunderbare Arbeit. - Danke.
Unsere Intensivstation ist voll.
Ich war noch nie
in meinem Leben so müde.
Wir haben hier schon viele grippe-
ähnliche Krankheiten behandelt,
auch Coronaviren.
Aber ich habe noch nie
eine Krankheit gesehen,
die sich so schnell verbreitet
wie diese.
Kollegen werden bei uns
eingeliefert. Enge Freunde.
Familienmitglieder. Natürlich hat
man da auch Angst um sich selbst.
New York hat so viele Tote, dass
die Stadt sich entschliessen musste,
einige der Opfer des Coronavirus
in Massengräbern auf Hart Island
zu begraben.
Auf dieser berüchtigten Insel
in der Bronx
fanden schon über 1 Mio.
namenlose Leichen ihre letzte Ruhe,
darunter Opfer der Spanischen Grippe
von 1918 und der Aids-Epidemie.
Nicht weit enfernt von Hart Island,
im Mount-Sinai-Spital,
versucht Eliane zu verstehen,
wieso das Coronavirus so tödlich ist.
* Piepsen *
Im Labor machen wir Nanopartikel,
die mit dem Immunsystem
interagieren.
Der Kontext mit COVID-19 ist,
dass die meisten Komplikationen
bei dieser Krankheit
nicht vom Virus selber kommen,
sondern von einer Überreaktion
des Immunsystems.
Mit unseren Nanopartikeln
versuchen wir, diese zu lindern.
Ich mache im Moment
sehr viele In-vitro-Dinge,
d.h., ich arbeite mit Zellen und
schaue, wie deren Immunreaktion ist,
wenn man sie mit LPS,
also Lipopolysacchariden stimuliert.
Während die New Yorker
weiter zu Hause bleiben müssen,
kämpft Eliane
auch heute gegen das Virus.
Es ist ein ganz besonderer Tag
für sie.
Ich werde heute 25.
* "New York, New York"
schallt laut aus dem Truck. *
Unglaublich!
Das ist so amerikanisch.
# I want to be a part of it,
New York, New York.
* Hupen *
Der Tag neigt sich dem Ende zu.
Der Abend wird anstrengend für David.
Er macht eine Lieferung
nach der anderen.
Diese Nacht sieht gut aus.
So verdient man Geld
während der Corona-Krise.
Harley macht seine letzte
Lebensmittellieferung:
in einem Klavierladen.
Magst du Steak? Isst du Steak?
Ihr seid drei, nicht wahr?
That's more than enough.
- Toilet paper? - No, we're good.
* Sanftes, sich steigerndes Stück *
Morgen wieder hier. Morgen wieder
hier, um den Kampf zu führen,
um Leben und Seelen zu retten.
* Sirene *
Es ist 19 Uhr.
Wie an jedem Tag
seit dem Beginn der Krise
klatschen die New Yorker
um diese Zeit
für das Krankenhauspersonal
und die Rettungssanitäter.
New York könnte Monate
oder sogar Jahre brauchen,
um sich von der Pandemie zu erholen.
New York, von dem es früher hiess,
es habe nie geschlafen,
ist und bleibt
eine unverwüstliche Stadt,
die irgendwann
wieder aufstehen wird.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Lilian Zbinden - 2020